if you had been taught equality from the
beginning you wouldn't be flipping out
but that's how hegemonic dominance works
if you're watching on YouTube right now
there is an algorithm that decides
whether you're subscribed to this show
or not whether you're going to be put
into the feed on any given day and see
my show what what is next to it on
suggested videos and if they if they
want you to oh you're watching Dave
Rubin we think you're thinking a little
too much like Dave Rubin we can get you
to think a whole bunch of other things
by clicking here and you go well all
right that's what the algorithm does
except the issue is that the algorithm
and Google's entire Google which is the
most powerful company in the history of
the world is now has now fully embraced
diversity equity and inclusion check
this video out this is Google's Dei
workplace training program it's called
racism white people's role and
responsibility if you had been taught
equality from the beginning you wouldn't
be flipping out but that's how hegemonic
dominance works and so I think that's
why it happens and we have to be willing
to talk about that because it's really
unhealthy this white anxiety is a Public
Health crisis in that regard and that's
why you know not only we were talking in
the other room a minute ago before we
came in here you know that that it's not
just the opioid crisis that we think
about with folks killing themselves
disproportionately increasingly white
working-class folks who are um you know
using heroin or using over-the-counter
uh opioids um but they're political
opioids turning to a candidate who says
you vote for me and I will take away
your pain I will bring back those jobs I
will make your life better that's a form
of an opiate as well okay so what's the
point of showing you all of this on the
day after the Iowa caucus when I should
be talking about hardcore Politics the
point is that all of these cultural
issues are the things that lead to
certain candidates right they are as
I've said repeatedly now the rocket fuel
the way the media behaves calling
everyone racist you're white kids we
don't care about them all of that stuff
is what led to the ground swell of
support for Donald Trump the the poit
politicization of our courts so that we
go after political opponents that is
what led to Donald Trump and everything
else